quatre ans après leur évacuation musclée
de l'église saint bernard à paris les
sans papiers réclament toujours la
régularisation de leur situation
cependant l'appel de la coordination
nationale des sans-papiers de nombreuses
organisations politiques 550 personnes
ont une nouvelle fois défilé dans les
rues de paris
je ne la souris il fut l'un des porte
parole des sans papiers de l'église
saint bernard pour un m'a dit camara
quatre ans après l'évacuation le 23 août
96 leur situation reste inchangée à
l'appel de la coordination nationale des
sans-papiers une trentaine
d'organisations politiques et syndicales
réclament des papiers pour les
sans-papiers l'abrogation des lois
pasqua debré et l'abolition des double
peine cette année l'association n'ait
obtenu que cette régularisation elles
demandent au gouvernement une politique
d'immigration plus souple et l'arrêt des
expulsions au moment où la france prend
la présidence de l'union européenne
l'ensemble des pays européens comme
l'italie et l'espagne
régulariser les sans-papiers nous ne
voyons pas trop mal c'est la phrase
n'aurait pas pris une décision sera
présent et tous les goûts oasis temps à
présent une régularisation globale
la coordination appelle un rassemblement
le 23 août prochain devant l'église
saint bernard